d'abord la désescalade est évidemment
mais surtout le rétablissement d'un
rapport de force qui conviennent à la
maison blanche joe biden était en
première ligne souvenez-vous en 2014
lorsque vladimir poutine avait demandé à
ses troupes de s'emparer ou en tout cas
de ces deux de ces mercenaires de
s'emparer d'une partie de l'ukraine
c'était l'annexion de la crimée une
humiliation diplomatique pour la maison
blanche une humiliation que n'a pas
oublié joe biden qui lui fait
particulièrement redouté les initiatives
de vladimir poutine à la frontière de
l'ukraine là l'une des solutions que
pour être opposé joe biden et pour
contrecarrer les plans soupçonné supposé
en tout cas par le pentagone de
d'envahir cette partie de l'ukraine est
tout simplement le soutien d'abord aux
armées ukrainiennes mais également aux
armées de l'union européenne membres de
l'otan qui sont également en première
ligne ce qui a justifié d'ailleurs que
la maison blanche s'entretiennent avec
les principaux leaders de l'union
européenne d'abord avant cet entretien
avec vladimir poutine mais il y aura
également un débriefing de cette
visioconférence dans l'après midi ici
aux etats-unis est également demain
emmanuel macron centre des sons
s'entretiendra directement avec les
conseillers de joe biden le l'un des
effets que pourrait produire le
pentagone on l'a dit c'est un soutien
militaire et financier aux armées qui
pourrait s'opposer à quelconque forme
d'initiative militaire russe en ukraine
même si au cours de l'entretien vadimir
poutine a répété qu'il n'avait pas
l'intention de s'emparer du territoire
ukrainien même même partiellement